aéroport de Nairobi dimanche 1er octobre
il est 5h du matin le Kenya est un pays
dangereux selon Washington ou le
terrorisme peut frapper à tout moment
j'ai la double nationalité française et
américaine
aujourd'hui j'utiliserai mon passeport
américain je veux vivre dans la peau
d'un de mes compatriotes
sur le site internet de l'administration
américaine on peut lire ces mots
enlèvement attaque suicide attentat à en
croire ce document le pays est une des
plaques tournantes d'Al-Qaïda en Afrique
dès mon arrivée à Nairobi je prends la
route de l'ambassade des États-Unis elle
est situé dans les quartiers les plus
chics de la capitale kenyane je sais
qu'aujourd'hui une proche de Colin
Farrell le ministre des Affaires
étrangères à rendez-vous avec les
expatriés
elle est là pour leur parler de la
menace terroriste
sur le chemin impossible de rater les
symboles de la puissance économique des
États-Unis mais un peu plus loin un
nouveau symbole sur J
Mecca Cola un substitut de la célèbre
boisson américaine le soda fait un
carton auprès des musulmans dans le pays
comme avec mon chauffeur il s'appelle
Khadija Mohamed
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre il
se sent menacé
c'est difficile d'être musulman Kenya
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus
pratiquer librement notre religion et ça
c'est à cause de la politique américaine
ils sont en train de voter une loi
antiterroriste qui nous interdire est de
nous habiller en bon musulman et même de
porter notre Kessi un autre coiffe
traditionnelle
que cette loi est mauvaise et que les
États-Unis font pression sur notre
gouvernement pour la faire adopter nous
ne voulons pas une telle ingérence
on approche bientôt de l'ambassade la
radio oui mais ne sors pas ta caméra ici
l'ambassade est très surveillée
ça te rend un peu nerveux
oui bien sûr
c'est
juste pour ça
des troupes d'élite de l'armée kenyane
boucle le périmètre impossible pour moi
de sortir la caméra
je vais tenter de rentrer dans
l'ambassade avec une caméra cachée elle
est dissimulé dans un sac à dos
[Musique]
le bâtiment est à 300 m de la dans un
second périmètre de sécurité difficile
d'y faire un attentat comme en 1998 y a
6 ans l'ambassade américaine se situe en
plein centre-ville une voiture piégée
avec les plus de 300 morts c'était la
première attaque d'Al-Qaïda contre des
intérêts américains
ici les consignes sont stricts personne
ne passe sans raison précise sauf bien
sûr si l'on est américain et je peux pas
prendre de photos de l'ambassade là non
non absolument pas c'est pour des
raisons sécurité
dans cette nouvelle ambassade la
sécurité a été renforcée rien à voir
avec l'ancien bâtiment et en plus ça et
de ne plus être en centre-ville
[Musique]
effectivement à l'intérieur du sas de
sécurité un détecteur de métal et une
machine à rayons X
[Musique]
ma caméra sera tout de suite
au guichet j'apprends que l'envoyé
spécial de Colin Powell a prévu une
autre réunion demain à mon bassin pour
la communauté américaine qui habite en
dehors de la capitale
je décide de me rendre
6h de route et quelques 450 km plus tard
me voici à Mombasa
c'est la perle de l'océan Indien le cœur
de la communauté musulmane au Kenya
ici le terrorisme a déjà frappé deux
fois
2002 une voiture piégée explose contre
l'hôtel Paradis et une attaque à la
roquette rate de peu un avion d'une
israélien depuis les touristes
américains ont disparu
mon chauffeur à mon bassin n'est pas
musulman il s'appelle Christiane pour
lui comme pour tout le monde ici depuis
3 ans la vie n'est plus la même
ici à mon bassin
vous avez des Américains était une vraie
mine d'or pour l'économie 6
mais depuis que le terrorisme a frappé
on n'en voit plus beaucoup
beaucoup
c'est un coup dur pour tout le monde
au nord de la ville le bord de mer et
c'est hôtel de luxe c'est dans l'un
d'entre que va tenir la Réunion barrière
de protection contrôle d'identité la
rentrée et surtout inspection du châssis
à l'aide d'un miroir des mesures de
sécurité sans se rassurer les touristes
la rencontre a lieu dans l'une des
salles de conférence de l'hôtel
je ressors ma caméra cachée
mais à ma grande surprise il n'y a aucun
dispositif particulier pour filtrer
l'entrée est de garde me l'as passée
s'embrouille et il ne me demande pas mes
papiers d'identité non plus
dans la salle une cinquantaine
d'Américains la plupart sont
missionnaire ou humanitaire cela fait
plus d'un an qui n'ont pas vu un
officier l'Américain mon bassin
je rencontre enfin Mora hardy l'envoyé
spécial de Colin Powell
avant même de pouvoir lui parler un
expatrié l'interpelle
ils sont tous musulmans ici et tout le
monde nous déteste on est
personnellement je n'ai jamais eu de
problème ni de menaces mais il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose pour
changer cette tendance cette haine
n'arrête pas de grandir ça en devient
ridicule
que l'on soit démocrate ou républicain
ça la même plus d'importance on nous
fait et à Washington rien n'est fait
pour changer l'opinion publique du monde
envers notre pays la réunion commence
j'en suis encore à me demander comment
on a pu me laisser approcher un
diplomate américain s'en fout il y avait
deux sacs c'est le chef de la sécurité
de l'ambassade qui prend la parole bien
sur son identité doit rester
confidentiel le discours et alarmiste le
risque terroriste est encore très très
en n'oubliez pas que nous vivons dans un
monde très violent l'actualité de le
rappel chaque jour les attentats
antiaméricain sont devenus monnaie
courante enlèvement assassinat attentat
ne sont que la partie visible de
l'iceberg les autres choses je préfère
ne pas les évoqué devant vous sachez que
pour moi il n'y a aucun doute
Al-Qaïda est encore au Kenya et son
idéologie va continuer à pousser des
gens à prendre pour cible les intérêts
américains dans la région
retour à Nairobi l'un des américains les
plus connus de la région accepte de me
rencontrer
c'est le PDG de General Motors le Titan
de l'automobile américaine Cadillac
Chevrolet son usine de Nairobi fournit
toute l'Afrique de l'Est
et une cible idéale pour les terroristes
et depuis le 11 septembre il a
transformé son usine en véritable quand
retranché les caméras de sécurité les
gardes sont omniprésents
regarde là-haut on vient de mettre une
nouvelle caméra
vous faites plus attention aujourd'hui
avec les personnes que vous embaucher
absolument
il faut savoir que des terroristes
peuvent s'infiltrer ici en tant que
ouvrier
tout ce qui leur faudrait pour rentrer
dans l'usine c'est porter un bleu de
travail
heureusement notre dispositif de
sécurité très efficace mais si moi je
vais travailler ici au Kenya quels
seraient vos conseils
c'est simple depuis 2 ans on ne nous
regarde pas de la même façon en Afrique
de la esta il faut donc suivre quelques
règles de bon sens éviter tout
rassemblement entre américain et aussi
éviter de le crier sur tous les toits en
fait il faut vraiment faire profil bas
rester discret et simplement apprécier
les qualités de ce fait magnifique il
travaille chez General Motors depuis 30
ans il tient à me montrer une des choses
les plus difficiles qu'il ait eu à faire
regarder ici se trouve et avant notre
grande enseigne General Motors elle
couvrait tout le haut du bâtiment
mais après le 11 septembre pour des
raisons de sécurité on nous a demandé de
faire profil bas et beaucoup d'autres
grandes entreprises américaines ont
suivi notre exemple
profil bas peut-être mais sécurité
maximum double grillage électrifié
patrouille de chien projecteur et
surtout une attention toute particulière
à la sécurité personnelle de Bill
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 ben il
est suivi par cette voiture escort à
l'intérieur se garde du corps ne le
lâche jamais même lorsqu'il pars en
weekend où on Safari
3 policiers dans la voiture de sport et
1 ans elle de Bill ils sont reliés entre
eux par contacteur radio il ne laisse
jamais plus de 10 mètres entre les deux
voitures
est-ce que beaucoup d'Américains sont
protégés comme ils n'ont pas tous les
Américains
VIP au Kenya
nous sommes des policiers des forces
spéciales nous avons été formés pour la
protection rapprochée et la lutte
antiterroriste
ben il ne pense pas que ces mesures de
sécurité soit excessive vous craignez de
30 V
bien sûr d'enlèvement a toujours été un
véritable risque pour les Américains à
l'étranger et me demande de changer mes
habitudes de ne pas prendre le même
chemin pour aller travailler et vous le
voulez bien sûr je change aussi mais
heure d'arrivée et de départ
bienvenue à Mussig le Beverly Hills de
Nairobi dans ce quartier tout le monde
vit sous haute surveillance
juste avant d'arriver chez Bill son
chauffeur actionne une télécommande un
signal préviens les gars de la maison
qui ouvre tôt si tôt les portes
de cette façon la voiture de ben il
n'est jamais immobilisé
les gardes du corps reste en poste même
à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de la
propriété que l'on soit à l'usine ou
chez lui il est obsédé par la sécurité
viens voir Diego je vais te montrer les
système de sécurité que j'ai fait
installer
une
caméra de surveillance et
j'appuie sur le bouton de la
télécommande de ma télé
j'en viens me demander comment ben il
fait pour vivre en état de siège mais je
ne suis pas au bout de mes surprises
bon et pour terminer dans beaucoup de
maisons de quartier nous avons ce que
l'on appelle une zone sécurisé
l'idée derrière ce concept c'est que
même si quelqu'un réussi à pénétrer dans
la maison tu le laisse faire ce qu'il
veut au rez-de-chaussée toi tu es à
l'étage tu t'en ferme derrière ses
barreaux dans ta zone sécurisée
sors et vous fait à tous les soirs
et tous les soirs et si quelqu'un
rentrer par effraction ça me donne le
temps d'actionner les alarmes depuis les
pièces du haut
la police arrive 2 minutes plus tard il
fait gris me permettre de tenir jusqu'à
leur intervention
une porte imprenable masturbe il met à
quel prix
si je regarde par la fenêtre je vois des
grilles des barbelés des murs en acier
mais j'ai vu ces choses à voir mais
c'était dans des prisons tu sais on s'y
fait à la longue ça fait partie de ma
vie aujourd'hui c'est le prix de ma
sécurité ici c'est pas fait pour
m'empêcher de sortir mais pour empêcher
les autres d'entrée c'est la grande
différence
ben il n'est pas le seul américain à
vivre dans une résidence autrement
sécurisé
dans le quartier de la nouvelle
ambassade des États-Unis Rajab montrer
lundi dernier projet immobilier en cours
il est exclusivement réservé aux
Américains depuis ce parking nous aurons
une vue imprenable sur le lotissement on
est où ici Radio
centre commercial
sur le parking
déverrouiller son supérieur lui demande
même par talkie-walkie que je présente
mes papiers
je tempère
décidément au Kenya passeport américain
égale sésame
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon merci à la
prochaine
[Rires]
pour un musulman ce serait bien de voir
un passeport comme ça ben oui bien sûr
tu en voudrais un toi j'avais un
passeport comme celui-ci je serai
vraiment très content ça se passe fort
je pourrais voyager partout sans
problème aller visiter l'Amérique autant
de fois que je veux
et un nom comme Mohamed je ne peux même
pas imaginer 15 jours je verrai
l'Amérique
Rajab pris dans le nez mosquées les plus
radical de Nairobi je lui demande si je
peux rencontrer son imam le cheikh
Mohamed
l'accepte mais il me conseille de me
présenter comme journaliste français
Amazon
il a raison à mon ex en Lima me prends
pour un américain il ne m'autorise pas
filmer finalement je l'ai mon passeport
français
parce que je parle avec un accent
que
vous m'avez dit que vous étiez et
votre façon de parler
Mike romain écoute-moi je vais vous dire
quelque chose nous les musulmans nous
sommes les amis de tous les êtres
humains et même des Américains
veulent pas de notre amitié
simplement parce que les gens là-bas
que diriez-vous américain qui vivent
derrière leur mur et leur barbelé
je voudrais leur dire simplement sortez
sortez nous sommes vos amis ce que l'on
vous dit ne sont que des mensonges le
Kenya et un petit bout de paradis
un petit bout de paradis sur terre
à Nairobi il y a aussi des Américains
qui refuse de vivre couper du monde
c'est dans le plus grand hôpital de la
ville que j'ai rendez-vous avec le
docteur David Silverstein
américain il est au Kenya depuis 24 ans
c'est l'un des directeurs de l'hôpital
il est respecté par tous
ceux qui veut dire docteur dans la
langue du pays
c'est bien ça
ce jour-là ce sont près de 800 blessés
qui affluent l'hôpital est complètement
débordé et David lui organiser des
secours tant bien que mal
à quoi pensez-vous ce jour-là
vous saviez que c'était un attentat
dans ces moments-là ma seule
préoccupation
américains qui sont morts nous on a
perdu plus de 250 kg
depuis les attentats les Kenyans sont
devenus suspects aux yeux de l'Amérique
le 11 septembre 2001 j'étais en route
pour New York
nous avons été contraints d'atterrir au
Canada
météorisme il ne s'en soucie pas plus
que ça
envoyer ses murs avec des morceaux de
verre encastré tout ça c'est nouveau
c'est juste pour se protéger de la
délinquance car moi c'est ça qui me fait
vraiment peur
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors pour échapper à la violence
urbaine David prend son avion privé
chaque vendredi après-midi direction ça
ferme à une centaine de kilomètres de la
en pleine savane africaine à peine
arrivé sur le tarmac de l'aéro club un
garde me demande d'arrêter de filmer
ils sont très paranoïaque ici
pourquoi à cause du terrorisme
je suis désolé mais ce sont les
Américains qui nous imposer ses règles
je recommence à pile mais après le
décollage
7000 américain continue à vivre au Kenya
malgré les risques
en survolant la savane au côté de David
je commence à comprendre pourquoi
tu vois ici la vie et bien plus
excitante aux États-Unis
j'ai tellement plus de liberté
avec mon avion je vais dans ma ferme
quand je veux
et puis j'ai un niveau de vie au Kenya
que je ne pourrais pas avoir en Amérique
à moi d'être multimillionnaire
j'ai bien quelque chose qui vous manque
au pays non
ma famille seulement c'est tout
ça y est
on est arrivé au paradis
sur la piste improvisée le chef
d'exploitation attends David avec un 4 4
10 minutes plus tard nous serons sur
cette terre
la ferme de David Silverstein est planté
au cœur d'une propriété de 50 hectares
un véritable havre de paix la première
ville n'est qu'à une trentaine de
kilomètres
dès mon arrivée je réalise qu'ici le
terrorisme la criminalité doit te
sembler très lointain pour nous
accueillir en a commandé la femme de
David
Bonjour Maurice tiens je te présente
Diego
ah désolé mon amour
tu aurais dû voir l'atterrissage il y
avait tellement de vent que j'ai pas de
carte de travers c'était génial
[Musique]
dis si on a une vue incroyable sur le
lac Naïvasha
à part que je préfère c'est le terrain
derrière la maison c'est vraiment
sauvage et c'est là-bas que je fais mes
randonnée à cheval j'y crois souvent des
buffles des Gazelles et des antilopes
aussi vous pensez qu'un jour vous vivre
dans un endroit pareil
c'est ça le réveil
en fin d'après-midi Rana veut me faire
partager son rêve nous partons à cheval
pour un petit c'est Paris l'occasion de
parler politique avec elle
être américaine à l'étranger c'est une
grosse responsabilité vous savez c'est
important de faire contrepoids la
politique américaine en ce moment elle
est si
dépourvue de tout vision 6 idiote qu'il
faut vraiment offrir une alternative
notre rôle
donné au reste du monde à visage humain
de l'Amérique et montrer quels sont nos
vraies valeurs voilà notre
responsabilité d'America expatrié
les sept vies d'expatriés je commence à
y prendre un goût certain c'est l'heure
du cocktail et ici on ne plaisante pas
avec les traditions
ouais tu l'as oublié
une catastrophe
je t'ai proposé un gin tonic et j'ai
oublié le jean lorsque j'ai chargé la
voiture
c'est génial des amis des Silverstein
les ont rejoint pour le weekend tous
sont amoureux de l'Afrique depuis plus
de 20 ans et vous Barbara vous
repartirez en Amérique
mets une vue imprenable sur le
même au bout du monde l'importance des
prochaines élections présidentielles
américaines et dans tous les esprits
peut-être mais moi quand on me demande
pour qui je vais voter je le réponds que
je voterai pour Kerry
dimanche matin je retrouve ben il est le
directeur de General Motors et sa petite
amie lui aussi tiens me montrer qu'il ne
plaisante pas avec les traditions
le seul endroit de Nairobi où les
Américains se retrouve pour prendre un
petit déjeuner typiquement américain
mais c'est un peu contre les
recommandations de l'ambassade
américaine nom de se regrouper comme ça
j'ai appris au cours de toutes ces
années passées en tant qu'expatrié que
nous les Américains nous aimons la
liberté
mais c'est une tradition américaine
et que l'on soit dans le monde nous
trouverons toujours un lieu pour nous
retrouver
à Nairobi cet endroit c'est le diable
house et comme sur les autoroutes
américaines il est collé à une station
essence ici on entre comme dans un
moulin aucune sécurité aucun contrôle
en quelques minutes le restaurant est
rempli d'Américains apparemment le
risque terroriste ne leur coupe pas
l'appétit
c'est
vraiment super c'est vraiment toute la
nourriture que j'aime regarde là tu peux
prendre des pancakes avec du beurre et
du sirop d'érable encore avec de la
banane et des noix
en fin de compte je te ré pour un
burrito extra-large avec du guacamole
et toi ben il t'a pris lesquels
je les ai pris nature c'est tout
aujourd'hui les gens qui vivent autour
de moi ou tu as un a priori négatif
parce que je suis américain
avant lorsque tu disais que tu étais
américain tu avais une véritable aura
les gens voulais te rencontrer
maintenant c'est plus américain ok mais
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ce qui se
passe en Irak alors lorsqu'on me demande
mon avis je réponds simplement je te
soutiens mon gouvernement et ses actions
et je pense que la planète est plus en
sécurité maintenant et en général parce
que je dise à la conversation s'arrête
net alors tu vas bosser pour qui
moi je suis républicain et je voterai
pour le président Bush
elle avait des élections présidentielles
les spécialistes disent que jamais
l'Amérique n'a été aussi diviser ce
voyage me le confirme ce qui est
peut-être vrai dans le Tennessee il est
aussi ici à l'autre bout du monde